this is race day my
start this helping him of his game with
his suit and the tech and all that good
evening Peter hello congratulations on
completing a train you have access
here's his full capabilities thank you
the chute is the coolest thing that has
ever happened to me was just a dream
come true
we have 500 on the apostle of your
combination Oh spend less Oh welcome our
web grenade reconnaissance drone whoa
that's really cool my hands combat mouse
I could make taser webs super Joe web
link there's always a real special
moment when I put the suit on this suit
when you want to do you like to hear it
in pain I can hear what they're saying
activating advanced reconnaissance man
I'm sick of sitting around haha I can
keep the suit of course son fit me
[Music]
you